Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
(Sirènes de pompiers)
Lundi 15 avril 2019. 18h18.
Plusieurs alarmes retentissent au sein
de la cathédrale Notre-Dame de Paris.
Le prêtre, les communiants et les employés
se dirigent vers la sortie
sans vraiment croire à cette alerte.
18h50. De la fumée s’échappe
de la toiture du monument.
Le filet de fumée s'épaissit.
Il devient gris.
Une odeur de brûlé
se répand sur l’Île de la Cité.
Les premières sirènes de secours
retentissent.
Les pompiers du cinquième arrondissement
arrivent.
A la radio, le ton est grave.
On demande immédiatement
des renforts très importants.
Les premiers camions de pompiers
s'orientent vers les tours.
On installe au dernier étage
les lances à eau.
Au total, 600 pompiers sont mobilisés
et 18 lances sont déployées.
À 19h50, la toiture est perdue.
Il faut désormais gagner
la bataille des beffrois.
La flèche de Notre-Dame s'effondre
sous le regard ébahi des badauds.
Le vicaire général de l’archidiocèse
de Paris dira plus tard :
« J’ai l’impression d’être
devant un bombardement. »
22 heures.
L'incendie prit une autre ampleur.
Il s’agit de sauver les trésors de la
cathédrale avant qu’il ne soit trop tard.
La situation devint critique.
La température dépasse les 800°C
et c’est désormais le toit de la nef
qui menace de s’effondrer.
Du plomb en fusion s’abat
à l’intérieur de la cathédrale.
Toute intervention humaine
est devenue impossible.
Les pompiers évacuent la cathédrale,
mais, un robot, seul, reste sur place
à braver les flammes.
Ce robot, il s'appelle Colossus.
Avec ses 500 kilos et sa résistance
à cette atmosphère insoutenable,
il a pour mission d’éteindre le feu
et de faire baisser la température
à l’intérieur de la cathédrale.
Ce robot est équipé
d’un canon à eau puissant,
capable de tracter des tuyaux
équivalant à la force
de 15 sapeurs-pompiers.
Et ce robot est téléguidé à distance
grâce à ses multiples caméras
qui détectent les points chauds.
Le robot devient alors
un outil au service de l’Homme
dans un environnement à risque.
Il faudra attendre 3 heures du matin
pour que l’incendie soit partiellement
maîtrisé par les pompiers.
Le robot, lui, est intervenu pendant près
de dix heures dans cette opération.
Cet événement a confirmé
que le robot Colossus n’avait pas pour
seul atout d’éloigner l’homme du risque,
mais également d’éviter des catastrophes
humaines, environnementales, destructrices
grâce à son action précise
au plus près des dangers.
Car Colossus n'en était pas
à son coup d'essai.
Il avait été utilisé
de nombreuses fois auparavant,
comme en janvier 2018,
lors d’un feu de parking souterrain
géant à Choisy le Roi.
Il avait été mobilisé
aux côtés de 120 pompiers,
pendant près de huit heures
et il était ressorti du brasier
avec encore 30% de batterie.
Une telle situation risque d’ailleurs
de se multiplier dans les années à venir
avec la circulation de plus en plus de
voitures électriques dotées de batteries
potentiellement dangereuses.
Aussi, en juin 2018,
lors d’une prise d’otages,
il était intervenu aux côtés des équipes
de la B.R.I et des pompiers de Paris.
Le forcené avait aspergé ses otages
de carburant.
Bref, ses usages sont multiples.
Pourtant, en 2017,
les premières fois
où l’on a présenté le robot Colossus,
il a parfois fallu se battre
pour susciter l’attention de décideurs
qui n’avaient jamais rencontré de robots
utiles et fiables dans leur domaine.
Et l’événement de Notre-Dame
n’a finalement que révélé au monde entier
l'intérêt de la robotique.
Cette année-là,
le Colossus a remporté le prix de la
technologie d’innovation aux États-Unis,
un pays pourtant
pas en reste dans ce domaine.
Et si le Colossus a été un outil important
dans la préservation
de notre patrimoine national,
c’est également une réalisation française.
La France a démontré au monde entier
qu’elle était capable de sauver
son patrimoine et sa mémoire
grâce à sa technologie.
Le futur a tendu la main au passé.
Le défi du 21e siècle qu’est la robotique
est venu en aide au défi du 12e siècle
que représentait la construction
d’un tel monument en France.
Car ce robot,
il a été conçu et fabriqué à la Rochelle.
Il est le premier-né d’un projet
entrepreneurial fou lancé en 2016.
Un projet tant innovant qu’inspirant
auquel nous croyons particulièrement.
Il réunit un tandem de choc :
Jean-Jacques,
notre Tony Stark de la robotique,
auquel vous ajoutez Cyril,
notre Captain America,
ancien des forces spéciales
de l’Armée de terre.
Leur but : apporter des robots
terrestres fiables et utiles,
capables d’appuyer l’homme qui
prend quotidiennement des risques.
L'ambition est grande.
Le terrain est vierge.
Personne ne s'était risqué dans ces
environnements jugés bien trop complexes,
avec la diversité des environnements,
des obstacles existants.
Conscients des enjeux d’innovation,
ces deux personnalités décident pourtant
de saisir cette opportunité.
L’initiative va à contre-courant
de ce qu’on voyait jusqu’ici
incarné dans la robotique,
avec des robots de logistique,
des robots automates
dont on craignait
qu’ils ne prennent nos emplois.
Il s’agit ici de donner du sens,
de l’utilité sociale,
un apport au bien commun,
à un domaine bien souvent
accusé de tous les maux.
Et en cinq ans, en seulement cinq ans,
pas moins de quinze types
de robots sont nés.
La démarche est atypique, car,
un, elle va au plus près des utilisateurs.
Comme aiment à le dire les militaires,
souples, félins, manœuvriers,
nous nous adaptons très rapidement
aux demandes de nos clients.
Aussi, cette approche très étroite
des utilisateurs, instaurée dès le départ,
va permettre à l’utilisateur d’adopter
très rapidement et sans encombre le robot,
car il aura été conçu avec lui.
Troisièmement, nos robots sont modulables
à l’infini, tels des couteaux suisses.
Comme les Lego de vos enfants, vous pouvez
changer les modules missions à l’infini,
pour transporter du matériel,
éteindre un feu, brancarder un blessé,
fournir une assistance respiratoire,
déminer.
Des modules missions à l’infini.
Et quatrièmement, ce robot
doit être facilement utilisable
car nos utilisateurs ne sont pas
des roboticiens,
et vous-mêmes, après une brève formation,
serez tout à fait capables
de piloter un de nos robots.
Et c’est ainsi que notre robot Colossus
a été le fruit d’une co-construction
avec les pompiers de Paris.
Un véritable dialogue s'est mis
en place depuis ce moment.
Un cercle vertueux pour innover
au plus près des besoins opérationnels.
S’en est suivie la création
du robot Atrax,
qui sert aujourd’hui
auprès des forces spéciales ;
le robot de décontamination Rhyno Protect,
qui a permis de lutter contre la Covid 19.
Je peux aussi vous citer tous les robots
qui servent aujourd'hui dans le nucléaire
évoluant dans des milieux radioactifs.
Une robotique utile,
au service de l’homme,
qui comptabilise chaque semaine
pas moins de 15 interventions.
Si aujourd’hui,
il ne fait plus aucun doute
sur le fait que la robotique puisse venir
en aide efficacement à l’humain
dans des environnements à risques,
utile, la robotique prend
alors tout son sens.
Elle devient alors vectrice de progrès
économique, sociétal et environnemental.
L’étape suivante nous emmène désormais
vers l’aventure spatiale,
un nouvel environnement extrême
nous plongeant immédiatement
la tête dans les étoiles.
On peut dépendre des robots
et ne plus pouvoir s’en passer,
mais... et si ce n’était pas
pour la bonne cause ?
(Applaudissements)